- We have two by two matrices here
and in other videos we talk
about how a two by two matrix
can represent a transformation
of the coordinate plane
of the two dimensional plane
where this of course is the x-axis
and this of course is the y-axis.
What we're doing in
this video is visualize
these transformations and
get a visual understanding
for why it's reasonable
for A to have an inverse
or for why matrix A is invertible
and why it's not reasonable
for B to have an inverse matrix
or why matrix B is not invertible.
So just as a reminder transformation
these transformation matrices
essentially tell us what to
do with our unit vectors.
For example, we have
the one zero unit vector
and the first column of
each of these matrices
tell us what the one zero unit vector
the vector that goes one
unit in the extraction
what it will get transformed
to under each of these transformations
and then of course you have
the unit vector in the Y
direction the zero one unit
vector and the second columns
here tell us how we would transform that.
So let's first think about
matrix A, matrix A transforms
the one zero vector
into the two, one vector
so the two, one vector is going
to look something like that
and it transforms the zero one vector
into the two, three vector
so the two three vector
is going to look something like this.
So one way to think about
it instead of our grid
looking like this grid
that I already had here
which is just our
standard coordinate axes.
This is defining a new grid
that would look like this
and I define this new grid
by looking at our multiples
of what the one zero vector
has been transformed into
and we also look at multiples
of what the zero one vector
has been transformed into.
So for example, if I were to
take this point right here
before it is transformed
it has one of each of these
vectors, well under this
first transformation
it would be one of each of these vectors.
So it's going to be one two one vector
plus one two three vector
so this point will be mapped
to this point and by that
same logic this point
right over here which is one
unit more in the extraction
well now it's going to have one unit more
in the direction that the X unit vector
has been transformed into
this point right over here
by the same logic will be one
unit more in the direction
that the Y unit vector
has been transformed into
so it will be there.
And that this point by the
same logic will be transformed
into that point and so this
region that I'm showing you
in white will get
transformed to this region.
Now there's some obvious
things going on here.
We have a two dimensional
area that has been transformed
to another two dimensional
area and in fact, it looks like
it has been scaled up in
other videos we have talked
about that this scale factor
is going to be the absolute
value of the determinant
of A and it's clear
that frankly, not only is this non-zero
but it's going to be greater
than what it looks like
we are scaling up our area
but the very fact that this
does not equal zero tells
us that we were scaling
from a two dimensional area to
another two dimensional area.
And so it's completely
reasonable to be able to go back
you will, for sure be able
to find a transformation
that takes you from this
region to that region.
So that makes us feel good
that A inverse is reasonable.
Now, as a point of contrast
let's think about matrix B
right over here.
Matrix B transforms the
one zero unit vector
into the two, one unit vector
so it transforms it into this unit vector
actually very similarly to how A did it
but then let's see what it
does to the zero one vector
transforms this vector
into the four two vector
four two is this notice
the four two vector
is just two of the two one vectors
is going in the same direction
it just has a different
size or different length
or a different magnitude.
So in this situation is taking things
in two dimensional space
and it's turning them
into combinations of things
that sit on this same direction.
So everything in two dimensions
is going to be mapped
to something along this line here.
So this region, if I were
to apply transformation B
it's going to be a region
of this line over here
anything, if I were to
map it using matrix B
is going to get mapped onto this line
so you're going to something with area
and then you're mapping it
to something that has no area
so the scaling factor here must be zero.
So we know since the absolute value
of the determinant of B is
zero, we could also fairly say
that the determinant of B is equal to zero
and the how are you going
to have an inverse matrix?
How are you going to have
something that can scale
from zero area to something that has area?
So we know that B inverse does not exist
there's nothing that can transform us back
and so there's a couple of things here
this reinforces this idea
that if your determinant
of a transformation matrix is zero
you're not going to have an
inverse, it's not invertible
the other thing to recognize
is seeing the patterns
in the matrix itself here we
saw that the second column
is just a multiple of the
first column it's twice
the first column two times two
is four one times two is two
you can also view it the other way round
the first row is a
multiple of the second row
and you can play around
with the math if you wanted
to generalize it and
see if that's the case
the determinant will always be zero
and that's because if you
view them as transformations
it's going to map to line
and you're gonna lose
all your area, if you view
it as a representation
for at least the left-hand
side of a system of equations
you can think about it as
lines that have the same slope
but we talk about that in other videos.